it's one of the largest and most
influential consulting firms in the
world but how much do you know about
what a corporate consultant really does
it's hard to imagine having more of an
impact on actual outcomes in the world
than working at a consulting firm
well no that one consultant who travels
the world works with the biggest
companies and to get some massive salary
they usually work at McKinsey and Co
Boston Consulting Group or some other
big name firm but what exactly do these
people actually accomplish well
theoretically they're supposed to bring
in an expert perspective in a specific
field or industry but more times than
not they're completely useless now
before I get clobbered in the comments
let me specify that I'm not talking
about technical consultants engineering
Consultants legal Consultants Security
Consultants and I.T Consultants can be
extraordinarily valuable given that they
truly possess expertise in this certain
area this expertise is often something
that many companies like internally so
they have to Outsource certain work to
these external firms but there is
another breed of Consultants who are
virtually useless management consultants
for starters the average consultant at
these big name firms are between 20 and
30 years old and over one third of them
have only been at the company for a mere
one to two years so how could a 25 year
old with two years of experience
possibly have any idea regarding how
apple or Microsoft or even a small
company should manage their business
these individuals have no management
experience whatsoever and everything
they know is theoretical and from a
textbook and I think we can all agree
that management isn't a skill that you
learn from a book or case studies great
management is something you learn from
years of leadership management and
actually doing the job that you're
managing the average Management
Consultant lacks all of these traits yet
they player often achieve six figures
out of college and over 200 000 by the
time they're 30. now you might be saying
that these Junior Consultants are
usually led by senior Consultants who do
know what they're doing but to that I
would argue that most companies have
internal staff that are more
knowledgeable than senior consultants
for example an internal program manager
who has 20 years of experience across
four or five big companies in a specific
domain will likely outperform a Senior
Management Consultant with a broad
experience every day of the week hearing
all this you're probably wondering why
in the world do top consulting firms
pull in tens of billions if they're so
useless well one thing's for sure and
not for their management expertise so
here's why companies actually hire
management Consultants
foreign
reasons that companies hire Consultants
aren't to break through various barriers
both internally and externally if you're
a high-ranking executive at a 10 plus
billion dollar company you're probably
going to have to handle a bunch of
politics this includes things like a
backstabbing and a blackmailing
colleagues trash talking competent
employees and intentionally withholding
crucial information why do people resort
to such measures you ask well it usually
has to do with the jealousy ego and
getting revenge for example Betty Who
works across from you and is obviously
less productive may get that promotion
before you do and suddenly you have to
report to Betty from your perspective it
Betty doesn't deserve that title and
you're honestly pretty salty that you
didn't get the promotion yourself so the
next time that Betty tells you to do
something you may be inclined to be
unresponsive push back or put up
unnecessary roadblocks usually you can't
justify such employees because you'd end
up laying off your entire Workforce not
to mention it in most cases such
employees aren't necessarily incompetent
or not hard working they just need
someone to get through their hard heads
and to get them to do what's right for
the business under management
Consultants one of the biggest roles of
management Consultants is to identify
pain points and to offer Solutions but
they won't actually make decisions for
you this is actually a big meme within
the industry people often criticize that
Consultants just tell you what you
already know and this is very much true
but the thing to note is that they do it
in a much more credible and reputable
fashion for example instead of just
saying that fixing a supply chain
bottleneck will save the company money
they'll actually get the numbers put
together graphs and create a solid
presentation virtually 100 of the time
they're gonna come to the same
conclusion as Betty but as an employee
it's much harder to say no to a 100 page
slide deck filled with the charts and
graphs than it is to say no to Betty's
seemingly subjective analysis ideally
instead of paying consulting firms and
arm and a leg to facilitate healthy
objective communication between
employees companies should work on
creating a better workplace culture but
that's much easier said than done also
if your company grows large enough it's
just a matter of time until there starts
to be a disconnect between the end
product and the average employee and at
this point it's just a matter of time
until you start to see rampant corporate
politics employees will no longer be
loyal to the product or customer instead
it they become loyal to their salary The
Prestige the job title and maybe the
performance review but that's pretty
much it meanwhile the employees who do
want to make change and produce impact
will no longer be interested in working
at your company this is truly an
unfortunate situation but you as the
leader can't just give in and let
employees do whatever they want so
you're often forced to bring in
management Consultants to break through
the corporate barriers across the
organization
Consultants aren't just useful at
breaking through corporate politics
they're also especially useful when it
comes to making hard unpopular decisions
this is particularly true in the current
economic climate because lots of
unpopular choices need to be made during
downturns for example this might include
shutting down a sector or laying off a
substantial number of employees and a
contrary to popular belief the vast
majority of CEOs don't want to lay off
employees for two reasons one they're
actually good people and they feel bad
cutting off so many people's incomes or
two they're cynical and they don't want
the bad press and reputation associated
with laying off so many people a perfect
example of the latter is Jeff Bezos back
in November on the same day that rumors
started to float around that Amazon was
going to do layoffs Jeff Bezos announced
that he would donate all of his wealth
to charity seems like an odd coincidence
to me but you can be the judge of that
anyway regardless of whether a CEO wants
to avoid layoffs for respectable reasons
or cynical reasons in the end they want
to avoid layoffs but at the same time
they know deep down that it's the right
choice for the business but how are they
going to convince thousands of managers
at tens of thousands of employees and
millions of investors to at least
somewhat agree with them while enter
management Consultants it will
essentially be the consultant's jobs to
justify the layoffs through objective
means for example they might make charts
regarding just how much money a
particular sector is losing and why the
ROI may not be worth it they may also
quantify how much money layoffs could
save the company and how discreet with
the company in a much better position in
case of a deeper recession once McKinsey
or BCG puts together all of this data
the CEO can send out the findings to the
various managers and the directors
across the organization followed by a
heartfelt message they can say something
like I really didn't want it to come
down to this but after seeing this 1 000
page report from McKinsey I feel that
there is no choice but to move forward
with these layoffs this report doesn't
just help the executives either it also
helps the various directors and managers
who will directly be laying off team
members that they've been working with
for years I mean these guys aren't
stupid they also know that making these
Cuts is the right choice but given that
they personally know the people being
laid off it's much harder for them to
pull the trigger they may even fight for
a certain employee or manager but the
McKinsey report does wonders when it
comes to making this process as smooth
as possible with all that being said
though you can bet that if the layoffs
work and the company starts doing well
again the CEO is gonna take all their
credit and say something like you know
it wasn't easy but I was willing to make
the hard choices when no one else wanted
to and that that's why the company is
where it's at today conversely if the
recession pass to buy quickly and the
layoffs turn out to be unnecessary and
they put the company a step behind the
competition the CEO can shift all the
blame to the Consultants they can say
something like you know I never felt
good about the layoffs that's why I
brought in McKinsey and it paid them at
30 million to do a thorough analysis of
the business and the industry and
unfortunately it doesn't look like they
did a good job as you can see management
Consultants are the perfect scapegoat
when it comes to justifying hard choices
and blaming them if the choices don't
quite work out
thank you
in the end objectively speaking
management Consultants are indeed
overpaid that weight one hundred percent
of the time they're gonna be less
experience than you they're gonna know
less about your business and or can I
come to the same conclusions and even if
they don't well it's not like you're
gonna listen to them anyway so
management Consultants rarely ever
provided any tangible value and in an
Ideal World they would be completely
pointless but we don't live in a perfect
world in the real world companies are
filled with politics bureaucracy drama
ego and it leaders want to deflect as
much responsibility as possible and it
turns out that management Consultants
are the perfect scapegoat when it comes
to dealing with all of these corporate
inefficiencies now I know that we've
been trashing on Consultants this entire
video but it's not all bad in fact from
a career perspective it's actually quite
appealing for starters you don't need
any technical skills you don't need to
know C plus plus or Java or the
intricacies of running servers or
networks you simply need to have a
strong communication and people skills
and while this doesn't come naturally to
all of us for most people looking into
Consulting it does aside from not
requiring any hard skills consulting
jobs often come with a lot of perks for
people who like to explore and
experience for example you won't be
doing the same thing over and over again
with each project you'll be working with
a new company traveling to new locations
and Consulting on different issues to
make things even better consulting firms
are often ranked extremely favorably
when it comes to company culture BCG for
example literally ranks number one when
it comes to employee approval of the CEO
Also let's not forget about the
compensation not only are you paid super
well but your entire compensation is in
the form of cash and bonus so for the
better or for the worse you don't have
to deal with any stock compensation with
all that being said though like any job
this job has its cons as well you'll be
working long hours you'll rarely be at
home you'll always be on call and at the
end of your career you'll have little to
quantify please show for all your work I
mean it's in the name of the job you
don't manage it you don't lead you don't
engineer you don't create and you don't
produce change instead it you simply
consult if you're an impact driven
person who wants to produce quantifiable
change throughout your career well
management consulting is probably not
for you however if you see your job as
just a means to an end and as a source
of income management consulting may be a
great choice for you you'll get to make
a bunch of money meet a bunch of people
and simply experience the world but just
keep in mind that these are the real
reasons that companies actually hire you
would you become a Management Consultant
comment that down below also drop a like
if this video gave you a better idea as
to why companies pay Consultants so much
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions are logically answered
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one